STEVE: 7:38 HERE IN NEW YORK
CITY.
BACK WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT.
THE CRUISE SHIP FLOATING OFF THE
CALIFORNIA COAST WITH 21
CORONAVIRUS PATIENTS ON BOARD
WILL DOCK LATER TODAY IN
OAKLAND, CALIFORNIA.
AINSLEY: ANYONE WHO TESTED
POSITIVE WILL IMMEDIATELY
DISEMBARK AND THEN HEAD TO THE
HOSPITAL FOR TREATMENT.
BRIAN: THE OTHER 3500 PEOPLE ON
BOARD WILL GO TO MILITARY POSTS
IN CALIFORNIA, IN TEXAS, AND
GEORGIA FOR TESTING AND A 14-DAY
QUARANTINE.
THE PROCESS IS EXPECTED TO LAST
SEVERAL DAYS.
SO LET’S BRING IN STEPHANIE
GRISHAM WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR.
STEPHANIE, ARE YOU COMFORTABLE
WITH THESE MOVES OR IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ASKED TO BE
COMFORTABLE WITH CALIFORNIA’S
MOVES?
>> GOOD MORNING.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD.
THE TASK FORCE LED BY VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE, OF COURSE, HAS
BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD WITH
STATE AND LOCAL OFFICIALS.
WE ARE GOING TO GET THAT SHIP --
WE ARE WORKING HARD TO GET THAT
SHIP HOME.
AS YOU SAID, WE WANT TO GET THE
MOST VULNERABLE OFF FIRST AND
EVERYBODY INTO QUARANTINE AND
TESTED AS APPROPRIATE.
STEVE: WE HEARD SOME OF THE NEWS
FROM THE TASK FORCE OVER THE
WEEKEND IS LIKE IF YOU ARE
OLDER, MAYBE YOU SHOULDN’T THINK
ABOUT GOING ON A CRUISE, THINGS
LIKE THAT.
HOW CLOSE IS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO HAVING ACTUAL
TRAVEL WARNINGS REGARDING, YOU
KNOW, AT WHAT AGE SHOULD YOU NOT
FLY ON AN AIRPLANE IF YOU HAVE
AN UNDERLYING CONDITION?
AT WHAT AGE SHOULD YOU CONSIDER
NOT TAKING A CRUISE?
THINGS LIKE THAT.
>> WELL, THE FANTASTIC FORCE IS
MEETING EVERY SINGLE DAY, AND
THEY HAVE BEEN GIVING DAILY
BRIEFINGS.
THE PRESIDENT IS BRIEFED EVERY
DAY, OF COURSE, RIGHT NOW WE ARE
TELLING PEOPLE TO ACT AS IF THIS
IS A SEVERE FLU SEASON AND WASH
YOUR HANDS OFTEN.
IF YOU ARE ELDERLY OR HAVE ANY
AILMENTS UNDERLYING HEALTH
ISSUES MAYBE DON’T GO TO AREAS
WHERE THERE ARE BIG CROWDS.
IF YOU DO START TO FEEL SICK
STAY HOME, DON’T GO TO WORK.
THINGS LIKE THAT.
RIGHT NOW THOSE ARE THE WARNINGS
WE ARE GIVING PEOPLE AND WE WILL
GO FROM THERE WE WILL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS AS THIS CONTINUES.
AINSLEY: STEPHANIE, WHEN BERNIE
WAS ON MEET THE PRESS OVER THE
WEEKEND.
CHUCK TODD ASKED HIM IF HE WAS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL BECAUSE WE KEEP
HEARING IF YOU ARE AROUND 80
YEARS OLD YOU ARE SUSCEPTIBLE.
AND HE IS 78 YEARS OLD.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS 73.
WILL HE CONTINUE TO HAVE RALLIES
AND BE OUT THERE ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL?
>> HE ACTUALLY JUST ADDRESSED
THIS.
YES.
HE PLANS ON STILL HOLDING
RALLIES.
I WILL TELL YOU WITH OUR
PRESIDENT, THIS MAN WHO DOESN’T
SLEEP AND WHO I HAVE SEEN WORK
15, 16 HOURS A DAY EVERY DAY, I
HAVE NO PROBLEM THINKING THAT HE
IS GOING TO BE JUST FINE AND
JUST HEALTHY.
STEVE: WHAT ABOUT THE FACT THAT
APPARENTLY THERE WAS A GUY AT
CPAC AND HE TESTED POSITIVELY
AND HE APPARENTLY SHOOK HANDS
WITH TED CRUZ AND TED CRUZ HAS
NOW GOING INTO SELF-QUARANTINE
FOR A FULL 14 DAYS.
APPARENTLY HE SHOOK HANDS WITH
MATT SCHLAPP AND MATT SCHLAPP
SHOOK HANDS WITH THE PRESIDENT.
IS THE PRESIDENT A LITTLE
FREAKED OUT ABOUT THAT?
>> NO.
NOT AT ALL.
AGAIN, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
LIKE A FLU.
AND SO PEOPLE ARE TAKING THE
APPROPRIATE PRECAUTIONS.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AS WE ALL KNOW IS QUITE A
HAND WASHER.
HE USES HAND SANITIZER ALL THE
TIME.
HE IS NOT CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
AT ALL.
I KNOW TED CRUZ AND CONGRESSMAN
GOSAR ARE DOING SELF-QUARANTINE.
YOU DON’T KNOW WHO EACH
INDIVIDUAL PERSON IS AROUND ALL
THE TIME.
PERHAPS THEY HAVE CONSTITUENTS A
LITTLE OLDER, ET CETERA.
THAT’S WHY THEY ARE MAKING THOSE
RESPONSIBLE CHOICES.
BRIAN: CONNECTICUT SENATOR
MURPHY THE NEW ADAM SCHIFF.
EVIDENCE GOES ON ALL THE TALK
SHOWS AND SAYS WE HAVE A
PRESIDENT LYING VACCINE TWO
MONTHS AWAY AND EVERYBODY COULD
GET A TEST WHO WANTED A TEST.
HE HAS TO BE STRAIGHT WITH THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IS HE MAKING EVERYTHING WORSE.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, I HAVE SAID THIS
BEFORE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID THIS
BEFORE AS WELL.
I JUST WANT TO STRESS TO
POLITICIANS AND THE MEDIA TO
STOP USING THIS AS A TOOL TO
POLITICIZE THINGS AND TO SCARE
PEOPLE.
IT’S NOT RESPONSIBLE.
THIS IS NOT THE TIME FOR THIS.
PEOPLE NEED TO BE LOOKING TO THE
CDC FOR GUIDANCE.
PEOPLE NEED TO BE, AGAIN,
WASHING THEIR HANDS, TREATING
THIS LIKE THE FLU, MAKING
RESPONSIBLE CHOICES.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY NOT THE TIME
TO TRYING TO SCARE PEOPLE TO
GAIN POLITICAL POINTS OR MAKE
HEADLINES.
STEVE: LET’S TALK ABOUT IN THE
LAST YEAR A LOT OF MORNING HAVE
HEARD ABOUT FISA THE FOREIGN
INTEL SURVEILLANCE COURT WHERE
ULTIMATELY IT WAS USED TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
NOW IT LOOKS AS IF CERTAIN
PROVISIONS OF THE FISA LAW ARE
GOING TO EXPIRE UNLESS THERE
LET’S MAKE A DEAL MOMENT IN
CONGRESS.
WHAT DOES THE PRESIDENT WANT AND
HOW CLOSE IS A DEAL?
>> WELL, I’M NOT GOING TO GET
AHEAD OF HOW FAR CLOSE WE ARE
WITH A DEAL.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID TIME AND
AGAIN AND I COULDN’T AGREE MORE
THAT THIS SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN TO
ANY CANDIDATE EVER AGAIN, ANY
PRESIDENT EVER AGAIN.
THERE HAVE BEEN FISA COURT
JUDGES WHO HAVE COME OUT
PUBLICLY SAYING THAT THOSE
WARRANTS SHOULD HAVE NEVER BEEN
DONE.
SO I THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
LOOKING FOR A BIPARTISAN EFFORT
TO TRY AND STOP THAT FROM
HAPPENING.
BRIAN: CLOSER?
DEMOCRATS JUST SAY LEAVE IT AND
LINDSEY GRAHAM WANTS TO CONTINUE
IT BUT WANTS SOME CHANGES.
WE KNOW WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF
PEOPLE ON HERE, MARK MEDLOWS
YOUR NEW CHIEF OF STAFF ON DOWN
SAYING THEY WANT SOME CHANGES.
IS THERE A SENSE THE PRESIDENT
WANTS TO SCRAP IT ALL TOGETHER?
>> NO.
I THINK, AGAIN, I THINK THE
PRESIDENT WANTS A BIPARTISAN
EFFORT HERE.
I THINK THERE IS DEFINITELY SOME
CHANGES THAT ABSOLUTELY NEED TO
BE MADE.
I THINK ONCE HE FEELS SATISFIED
THAT WHAT HAPPENED TO HIM AND
WHAT HAPPENED TO HIS CAMPAIGN
WILL NOT HAPPEN TO ANOTHER
PRESIDENT OR NOMINEE AND I WOULD
SAY DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN, THEN
I THINK WE WILL MOVE FORWARD.
AINSLEY: HILLARY HAS BEEN
INTERVIEWED A LOT LATELY AND
THERE IS THAT LULU DOCUMENTARY
ON HER FOUR-PART SERIES.
SHE WAS ALSO INTERVIEWED ON CNN.
LISTEN TO WHAT SHE SAID ABOUT
WOMEN AND THE DOUBLE STANDARD.
>> THE DOUBLE STANDARD,
PARTICULARLY IN PUBLIC LIFE, AND
NOT ONLY IN POLITICAL PUBLIC
LIFE BUT BUSINESS LIFE, LIFE OF
THE MEDIA, AND THE ARTS AND SO
MUCH ELSE, YES, THERE IS SOME
SALUTE MISOGYNY THAT CERTAINLY
LIVES ONLINE.
BUT THERE STILL IS SOMETHING
INSIDE THAT WHEN A WOMAN SAYS
WAIT A MINUTE, I WOULD LIKE TO
LEAD, I WOULD LIKE TO BE IN
CHARGE, I WOULD LIKE TO BE YOUR
PRESIDENT OR YOUR CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OR WHATEVER IT MIGHT
BE.
LITTLE ALARM BELLS, LITTLE
UNCONSCIOUS ALARM BELLS START TO
RING.
AINSLEY: DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> NO, I DON’T.
I THINK THAT ACTUALLY SHE IS
MINIMIZING WOMEN WITH THOSE
COMMENTS.
YOU KNOW, ACTUALLY UNDER THIS
PRESIDENT, WOMEN ARE DOING
BETTER THAN EVER, ESPECIALLY
WITH JOBS.
AND I WOULD SAY JUST PERSONALLY
AT THE WHITE HOUSE HE HAS GOT SO
MANY WOMEN IN LEADERSHIP AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WOMEN ARE DOING GREAT.
AND I THINK THAT TO PLAY THAT
CARD AND TO PUBLICIZE THAT CARD
ACTUALLY MINIMIZES WOMEN AND
DOES THE OPPOSITE EFFECT OF WHAT
I THINK SHE WAS TRYING TO DO.
BRIAN: THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS NOT GOING TO
ATTEND A SAINT PATRICK’S DAY
LUNCH AND FIRST TIME A PRESIDENT
HASN’T ATTENDED IN DECADES
REALLY BECAUSE OF THE PRESENCE
OF NANCY PELOSI AND IF I CAN
PARAPHRASE HE BASICALLY THINKS
SHE HAS BEEN DIVIDING THE
COUNTRY.
IS IT WORTH MISSING AN EVENT
BECAUSE OF NANCY PELOSI’S
PRESENCE?
>> YEAH.
I THINK THAT RIGHT NOW HE HAS
GOT A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
HE HAS BRIEFINGS ON THE
CORONAVIRUS.
WE WILL BE DOING OUR OWN THING
AT THE WHITE HOUSE FOR SAINT
PATRICK’S DAY.
I THINK IT’S EXACTLY TRUE.
WE DON’T NEED TO DEAL WITH ANY
MORE OF HER, YOU KNOW, LITTLE
GAMES AND HER LITTLE RIPPING UP
OF PAPER.
WHO KNOWS WHAT SHE HAS PLANNED
FOR THIS.
THAT’S NOT WHAT THE COUNTRY
SHOULD BE FOCUSED ON IS HER
GAMES AND POLITICS.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO STAY
AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
STEVE: HE WON’T BE ATTENDING THE
SPEAKER’S LUNCH.
HER DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF PUT
OUT A STATEMENT AND SAID THERE
HAS NEVER BEEN STRONGER SUPPORT
IN THE CONGRESS AND IN THE
COUNTRY FOR THE U.S.-IRELAND
BILATERAL RELATIONSHIP.
ONE WOULD THINK THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE COULD SET PETTY, PARTISAN
POLITICS ASIDE FOR THIS HISTORIC
OCCASION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I FIND THAT TO BE LAUGHABLE,
ABSOLUTELY LAUGHABLE.
AND HIS NOT ATTENDING A LUNCH
DOES NOT MEAN THAT ANYTHING WITH
NORTHERN IRELAND IS ANYTHING
LESS THAN GREAT.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT.
VERY GOOD.
STEPHANIE GRISHAM JOINING US